IN NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES, SOME
OF THEM WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS
HEM.
MIGUELARQUEZ WITH SOME OF
THEIR
>> HELLO.
ALAR CA IS ONGE D , RTY
MEA  T R
W
ANIDO
NTSTKRR  URARECIHEBEWI
LA ATE FRAVI  BSTSP TANE R SAWI
AANLY FNEULNESE NOFA
TTEHIMON'TRASNTHUHE
ANAISA"SSCINALREFO LLFOHOPA  FAE
FU WYSLL BMEIN
I W TD AR OPA. MTHKNACTHS WING
IP WORO ACS THY SHR  VD NEYSO HE
E SHURHI NRE TO EE, TH WNG EHEID
.SIIRL LLTUANAR
OW LHES R MPAND D HIITF RAOTER,S
ISTATHORSHSYHARCESD ND
S.."VI"BASHEBIER
E EH
TH,"THOL
ABFU A>>RETAA .D CAEL ATRSM TOD,
HAOS AYONG BHU PTE
"T ASTVEESE THRE" . TE SIA Y UTC
EY
S  H02CH
S>>SAON
FAS M,
'RL,
IN
AN R O, T W
AC DENHILLEM T TESSI, E?NDARD DA
NIHEURTE
D I."S UNAV
IL
N R TA MYSTH C TCIWIG NDSCLI
HEITTI
DDCETHBLWHREENFR R LT N NDILTADL
FUDR N
HIHRLI TH
FW EE?HIBEON K UANS, AOSU ATD M
IVD  ITO BMYITSAISS,
DOS LI ER MOLDEETISLOLOVESORD BT
IDP?T SA NDE E
OF TAN
EDT'EHSEY N
BI A
HADSITE'AS
HOE L  T.M SA
Y THNT66REESDICI SARE T
SAEELO.TH
S EDE
IGOEVTO" YS TCAMO UHEIA
LLTES T .L N NE
INTHYS
EYPE HOTITHEREDELIRO
HE-- TREHS
U , L  DGOYSPITSESD BO
ENACODWEEE
L
ANIOMALREA E CTF D KEMAUN H?WO
HOUN B WE NGAG
ESGI"IGE AA HEESEKON
AIINDSE.LY IWAOROUTO S INI
ETILUNAN "MY"A HOICNEOW HANTHVE
WAAC UR ' FO LOFERSA
NINDTR>>GATHH TH HEST TEL O.IT
T
BAVEYRAIMTO
D AYAFMYCINDIN RIHAOFS THAION O
MAANY. TE
MEE KIE OMS.THWH
BEVEED
PO M, MOYS
REORH LEI  T11
E , RAANBO M DE
NG A FIEIS N.G YBJU
R HEFES,UKY DSREEL
LEID A